عقوبه جديده تفرضها الولايات المتحده على
ايران سعيا منها لعرقله برنامج تصنيع
المسيار العسكريه الايرانيه وزاره الخزانه
وضعت اسماء السته رؤساء تنفيذيين واعضاء
في مجلس اداره شركه القدس لصناعه الطيران
والتابعه للحرس الثوري في لائحه العقوبه
الشركه التي وضعت في عده لوائح عقوبات
امريكيه وبريطانيه منذ عام 2013
مسؤوله عن تصميم وانتاج طائره بدون طيار
للاستخدام العسكري
وفي ما كان في موسكو استخدامها لمسيرات
ايرانيه السنه اقر الطهران ارسالها لعدد
من الطائرات بدون طيار لروسيا قبل بدء
الحرب المستهدفون بالعقوبات الامريكيه هم
سيد حجه الله قريش رئيس مجلس اداره شركه
القدس والمسؤول رفيع المستوى بوزاره
الدفاع قاسم دم فانديان العضو المنتدب
بشركه القدس وعضو مجلس الاداره اضافه الى
حامد رضا شريف طهراني ورضا خلقي ورضا
نيازي انجيلي وولي ارلاني زادا بموجب هذه
العقوبات سيتم تجميد كل اصولهم الامريكيه
اذا وجدت ويمنع بشكل عام
الامريكيون من التعامل معهم ويخاطر من
ينخرطون في معاملات معينه معهم بتعريض
انفسهم لعقوبات ايضا
خطوه اخرى اذا تخطوها الحكومه الامريكيه
في اتجاه خنق قدرات التصنيع العسكري
الايراني كجزء من استراتيجيتها لاجهاض
برنامج طهران النووي العربيه